now to the coronavirus and efforts to
reverse its economic impact the National
Bureau of Economic Research declared
yesterday that the u.s. is now in
recession a few hours later the Nasdaq
stock index closed at an all-time high
or lead national correspondent that's
David Berg now shows how the former US
epicenter of the pandemic is finally
starting to reopen people across New
York City Monday phase one was in full
effect retailers were readying those
curbside orders construction workers
were back on the job
there's the Governor Andrew Cuomo he
took the subway to work yesterday to
reassure nervous New Yorkers he also had
a warning
you have to stay smart after the
reopening because if you don't you can
see a spike that is the last thing that
we want to see every state in the
country is now partially reopened but
you should know gathering with friends
in a pandemic has its risks that's a
lesson some people learned down at the
Jersey Shore over Memorial Day weekend
did almost everyone at this party could
say yes most people did yes that's dr.
David dams Kerr he is director of the
health department in Bucks County
Pennsylvania he says about a dozen of
his residents in Bucks County went to a
party in nearby New Jersey and they all
contracted the virus how many of them
wore masks from our experience people
were not wearing masks on Monday the
World Health Organization announced that
recent global data suggests a
symptomatic transmission of the virus is
very rare made CBS news medical
contributor dr. David agus believes that
announcement was irresponsible
asymptomatic people fall into two
buckets one is people who will be
asymptomatic for the whole course of the
virus and the others who are we called
pre-symptomatic sure they're
asymptomatic that they will get symptoms
in several days in both cases they can
transmit the virus so this announcement
should not change behavior
good morning from Central Park if you're
going to travel this summer here's the
guidance from the health experts
unless you've been able to quarantine
what the person you're traveling with
you should stay at least six feet apart
wash your hands regularly and commonly
disinfect those surfaces masks work
that's what the experts tell us so masks
continue to be encouraged but you know
what's not encouraged hugging someone
and Gail I don't know about you but I
have not touched the skin of a human
being in the last three months and I
sure could use a hug right now yeah yeah
you and me both David you don't want to
hear that story
coming from my husband listen there is a
different energy I haven't left the
house but there was a different energy
looking outside you could see that
people are out but I like what Governor
Cuomo said stay smart and you're
following all the advice so David Beck
no thank you and I can't wait to hug you
once again I mean that